yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
King Charles didn't exactly receive a
warm welcome during his visit to York
the Mauna Kea is at a real Crossroads
now Charles carries a great weight on
his shoulders because
he's going to be a transitional King by
his age alone the sharking moment went
down as his majesty greeted crowds at
middlegate bar a royal entrance to the
city
[Music]
but as Charles made his way to the other
side of the street a protester pelted
eggs at him
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah the man missed and was detained by
police following the incident and the
King well security whisked him away and
he continued his Royal duties
[Applause]
we are going to have the reign of King
Charles III he's not going to waste any
time getting to work pretty quickly
Charles and his wife Camilla visited
York for the unveiling of a new Statue
of his late mother Queen Elizabeth at
yorkminster the Statue was completed in
August one month before her passing
there's always vigilance of all the
wealth of people during her life
[Applause]
we've seen him hit the ground running I
think we're going to see him make trips
to the Commonwealth continue this this
real high visibility around the United
Kingdom doing everything he can to keep
the United Kingdom together Elizabeth
died at the age of 96 in September after
70 years on the throne Charles the new
reigning monarchs coronation is set to
take place in May 2023 and I think we're
going to see the entire coronation when
that comes be televised you know Charles
has to have that connection with the
people in order I think to be seen as
relevant to have that connection we're
in a different age and you know I think
the queen did manage to retain that
Mystique of monarchy
that's going to be the challenge for the
current King and even more so for the
next generation of royalty
[Music]